during the opening stage you were
constantly looking at ding did you
expect some body language to reveal
anything important and did he give away
that he was caught in in your
preparation
I mean after after they uh yeah I
already missed him yeah so a little
yeah a little
like that before the match began Magnus
was asked who he thinks will win and he
said I literally don't care at the
beginning of your game today he posted a
picture of himself and it said Astana
calling which suggests that maybe he is
starting to get interest in the match do
you think he's following the match
closely uh
as they say I literally don't care yeah
well said I guess he's turning into his
dream area or something
since this is a famous quote from from
another a very very strong player here